no I think the thing is Andrew you are a
straight talker right and that's one of
the things I think so many people love
about you you say absolutely as it is
and my fear is if you say real estate's
dangerous this is dangerous that's
people will not know what to do and
they'll end up doing nothing extra money
in the bank that's true help us out okay
that's true help us out when I say real
estate it's dangerous now firstly you
can make money with real estate you can
make money with real estate
I'm not saying it's dangerous from that
perspective I'm talking about my own
personal ideology my personal ideology
is I don't want to be within control of
a government I don't want a government
to control me
if I didn't think that way then I'd be a
lot less opposed to real estate I mean a
house is always going to be worth
something and I'm gonna go to zero you
know it's not like a risk like a crypto
yeah uh or a stock that can go to zero a
house will always be worth something and
you can definitely make a lot of money
in it I'm just at the position where I
just don't want to have a government to
have control over me and this recent War
approved it look at all these
billionaire Russians who fair and square
bought properly in London by the law
paid their price paid the stamp Duty
stuck to the rules
then the president of their country did
something who's they may not even agreed
with it who do they know do you agree
with everything the Prime Minister does
now no neither do I and then the British
government came along just took all
their houses off here's my status if you
have gold silver anything specially
money in the bank it can if you go down
the extreme levels enough it can get
taken oh that's true nothing nothing on
this Earth is Freehold everything is
lease old to a degree there are certain
things which can't be taken like you
won't give us one example though so it's
hard to there are some things that can't
be done okay but I think that property
yeah is one of the hardest things for
them for anybody to take you can make a
lot of I make a lot of money in property
without owning it as well yeah but I'm
controlling it absolutely and also being
a property entrepreneur I I can't say
you don't make money in real estate and
I'm also not saying I don't own anything
you do own property of course I do but
I'm just saying that I don't feel
comfortable I don't go ah bought another
house yes let me sleep easy some guys do
but I think when you truly I mean you
know what I'm doing right now flipping
land and all that kind of stuff like you
know a few years ago many people said to
me oh real estate's risky I've made
millions in real estate I bet you have
it's all I know I bet you have and
through controlling it flipping it
trading it owning it completely and my
properties are a lot are in my personal
name I've got a lot in company as well
now I think I'm in a pretty safe
position now if it gets so bad that they
take away everybody's property and the
world has ended and there's this massive
plague and everybody's dead you know
what I lived a pretty good life no
completely and I understand a lot of
people will see me as paranoid and
that's fine but um I know you can make a
whole bunch of money but the last thing
I I'm currently in a situation where I
don't need money so I'm just trying to
position myself in a way that I sleep
the best as possible yeah and I don't
feel I don't feel happy with money in
the bank either I don't that's the worst
not because of even inflation like I if
I look if I load up my bank balance and
it's 87 million dollars
that doesn't make me feel comfortable it
makes me feel the opposite right because
the one day you click on the app sorry
contact customer service that you're
like yeah [ __ ] yes you [ __ ] well
just do that [ __ ] to you so it's like I
don't like money in my Banks I Don't
Like Money in a house it's hard I know
it's hard up to the first 86 000 pounds
so if you've got a couple male and then
the bank goes bust gone I'll give away
one of the things I like to do just one
so I like I like personally I prefer the
idea of digital real estate
because digital real estate is not
controlled by one government
jurisdiction and it can be owned by some
obscure
entity so let me give an example let's
say I were to buy www.money.com
that's worth money if I can put anything
on there and generate money so that's
worth money I'd pay a lot of money for
it yeah and let's say that was owned by
a Singaporean Trust
boom yeah I feel safer with that okay
okay no that's interesting that makes
sense yeah it makes sense because now if
anyone wants to find out who owns
money.com even though I've just set it
here on this podcast they're like look
it up some Singaporean trust okay
contact the Singapore authorities who
owns this trust we can't tell you Court
in Junction
years and years and years and years yeah
it's it's complicated and I I feel like
I own it more more than a house see it's
interesting and I think my attitude is
you've got to invest in what you know
yeah if you've made a lot of money you
should invest in what you know oh
completely I don't invest in certain
stuff if I don't understand it
completely and even if people tell me
this is a great investment this is a
great coin I'm thinking I'm all good
thanks yeah because I want to invest in
what I understand and if you understand
digital assets yeah I mean for me
personally I think owning a website or a
link would for me would feel more risky
because I can just see any minute bang
can't open it I'd rather own land where
even if there's a war and the house gets
knocked down I've still got the land I
have a shortage of land I understand you
know I understand but and there's so
many ways to skin a cat that's what's so
beautiful about making money right I I
completely understand that my my block
is ideological not I'm not saying it's a
bad idea I know that a lot of money can
be made however
let me give a caveat to that oh here we
go
I do think that most of the ways money
is made on the planet nearly all of them
yeah are Ponzi schemes I think stocks
are a Ponzi scheme
and when I say Ponzi I mean that if
you're in early you make a bunch of
money and if you're in late you get
wrecked money doesn't come from the thin
air money doesn't come from the sky so
let's look at crypto right A lot of
people ask me about crypto hey what do
you think about this going what do you
think about this coin most people don't
understand that the crypto Market is
player versus player
and it's funny because these new crypto
coins launch and they start these
telegram groups these communities and
all the people who have bought the coin
are in this community and they're all
like acting like they're friends you're
not friends yeah if you bought it at a
dollar and you want to sell it at a
profit of ten dollars someone has to buy
it off you
so you're it's not it doesn't just come
from the sky you're selling it for more
than you bought it for right so a bunch
of people get in money comes in price
goes up and up and up and up and up and
up there's always going to be a guy who
bought the top yeah and it never goes up
anymore yeah and he gets screwed there's
x amount of people at the top who get
wrecked so the people at the bottom can
make money yeah it's a Ponzi every
crypto is a Ponzi all of them I could go
get 100 million dollars right now
go to England walk around and make a
bunch of money in real estate because I
got liquid cash I'll take that I'll take
that and take that I've got all the time
in the world might take me nine years
that'll go up yeah that'll go up that'll
go up that I could do it but there's
also
Bob and Sally working their ass off
22-year mortgage 10 interest rate
when we own our home Sally then we'll be
okay don't get me wrong I think that
property
um is something that can be bad I think
that buying your own home I mean I think
that the help to buy scheme is a scam
because I'm a developer okay so while I
build houses and the help to buy scheme
is not help to buy it's helped to sell
yeah yeah because basically the people
that are getting bought into the help to
buy the government are loaning them the
money they have to fight back yeah it's
only applicable to a new build it's only
applicable if you live in it yeah so the
it's really to encourage the developers
to buy a bill and Vlog off their stock
at an expensive price and then the
people that are buying it
the second that they buy it drops in
Vegas new build 100 they've got to live
in it they're in negative equity they're
they're finished so the help to buy
scheme I guess is a way of investing in
property or not even investing a way of
buying property I don't think you should
do that I think that before you buy your
own home to live in I do own my own home
yep but I only bought it last year after
making millions yep so I think before
you buy your own home if you're ever
going to
become a millionaire first oh no
completely there's there's so much to
say for renting because when you rent
your flexibility yeah true I think that
flexibility if we're talking about the
attention economy and we're now living
in a world where things are changing so
rapidly think of how different the world
was 10 years ago yeah ten years ago we
had Motorola razors couldn't even do a
video on our phones now now we can film
Hollywood movies yeah like it's crazy
how fast the world's changing if you're
gonna say for 22 years I'm going to live
at this address you're a dummy because
you might get an opportunity in Japan
who knows right you're a dummy to do
that so I agree I I own the house I live
in no sorry I don't an entity in a
company blah blah owns the house I live
in
that was a cache and that's only because
I wanted it the way I wanted it I want
to renovate all this I want bulletproof
glass okay just play it yeah that's why
I did it but in general yeah you should
you should renting allows you
flexibility yeah and flexibility is very
important in the modern world to get
rich to get rich you might need to have
to go here or go there you might need a
month over there you might want to go do
something in Ireland for two months and
then also another thing about renting
especially in the western economy I know
I shouldn't say this and it's probably
going to piss off your guys but it's
true there's really very little downside
to renting because even if you don't pay
your rent they can't make you leave like
it's [ __ ] clown world over here like
oh you're renting uh three months you
don't even pay your rent and you're
still [ __ ] sleeping fine yeah so the
whole thing is like rent rent is
fantastic I would only recommend renting
unless you get to the point like you we
have so much money that's why our
tenants are guests not tenants good I
like that so they don't have the same uh
well I live in Romania so we have my
tenants because I do have tenants we
have a slightly different system in
Romania or an hour late bro keep our
Packer pay but um you know what the the
the they make it really strict to try
and help the tenants but what actually
happens is the landlords directly no the
landlords become really strict with the
vetting process yeah of course ask for
big deposits yeah my sister's trying to
rent somewhere she's a single mom and
the letting Edge said we don't rent to
single moms yeah right so what's
happened is it's actually her in the
tenants of course yeah so it's all the
all the things that the government do to
try and help the poor often end up
hurting the poor why don't we what did
we say earlier about about trying to
give money out the government the
government's not capable of helping the
poor and this is why it's so important
as a person you take personal
responsibility and understand you're
living in a world where the Matrix can
be cracked you can make a bunch of money
but you need to take responsibility and
do it and they're close to bank and
stuff yeah yeah they close bank accounts
Payment Processing they it's yeah unless
I mean own the money right yeah your
your bank account but they didn't take
your properties off you well they can't
yes exactly but but that's because of
how I've set things up right so you need
to be smart on how you do it yeah do it
through a company well that's right but
I also think that Joe schmoe who's just
starting off buying his house doesn't do
a smart absolutely you know what though
in the UK the devastating landlords the
taxes everything they're killing
landlords but the rich corporations that
are investing in property the way
they're doing it it's very profitable
completely and so the small guy needs to
learn how the big guy's doing it and
duplicate it